Instagram which way will it go the race
to elect a new conservative party leader
and prime minister now officially on and
the timetable set we have agreed Way
Forward uh for the leadership election
we expect 20 supporters for each
candidate we'll also expect that on the
first ballot any candidate to proceed
must have won at least
30 votes this is a terrible distraction
for the country for the party for the
government you are surely worried about
your party's reputation in this absolute
mess I'm very keen that we get this
concluded as smoothly thinly and rapidly
as possible and certainly we should have
a conclusion and the new leader of the
party elected and announced on the 5th
of September
right place to be the next prime
minister the foreign secretary the 11th
candidate to put herself forward joining
front runner Rishi sunak in a crowded
field our leadership has to change my
case for leadership is simple I want the
best for us all and I'm the person to
deliver that this the largest list of
candidates in any conservative
leadership election and the Rivalry is
Rife it's getting nasty though isn't it
Mark I haven't decided Beth thank you I
think it's important to have a Clean
Campaign that already difficult
Chancellor and candidate Nadeem sahawi
allegedly under investigation for his
own tax Affairs allegations around your
tax Affairs going to torpedo your bid
sir
but still a pitch for radical proposals
tax as a percentage of GDP will fall
year on year if I become Prime Minister
that is a promise and this man former
health section wants a Chancellor two
today like others feeling the heat oh
it's hot in here and Under Pressure to
justify his candidacy after turning on
Mr Johnson despite months of defending
the status quo it seems to me that
perhaps you're a continuity candidate
and your selling point is I'm not Boris
Johnson I'm a man of integrity and
that's about it I did think about
leaving earlier than I did but every
time I just I convinced myself that to
give the benefit of the doubt and
perhaps I did it for too long perhaps I
should have left earlier but I didn't
see anyone else leave any earlier than
me but now pledging to scrap the rise in
National Insurance he previously backed
you supported the social care Levy as
Hull secretary you supported the ni tax
rise which you'll now say in your cut
now some people look at that and say
you're talking out of both sides of your
mouth what's your response to that the
circumstances have changed I think at
the time the general Assumption of
inflation for the next few was around
three percent now we're at 10 inflation
the pressure now off this man Mr
Johnson's day is now numbered as he
appeared in public for the first time
since his resignation speech at a
science research center use talked about
the herd in Westminster you said when it
moves it moves and it certainly
stampeded on you last week do you feel
betrayed look I I don't want to say I
any more about all that there's a
there's a contest underway and that must
happen and you know I would wouldn't
want to damage anybody's chances by
offering my support I just have to not
to get on a pillar of anger I have to
get on and in the last few days and
weeks the the job of the Constitutional
function of the Prime Minister in this
in this situation is is to discharge uh
the Mandate Boris Johnson has just eight
more weeks to do that as his would-be
successes engage in a ferocious battle
to replace him this a contest is wide
open as it is unpredictable bath Rigby
Sky News Westminster